hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
i am unfortunately a bit under the
weather today i am so proud of not
having gotten sick for a whole three
years i think it's the longest
time in my life when i have
not once gotten sick but i seem to have
some kind of
developing cold um
and so i'm a bit under the weather and
maybe less coherent than usual
we'll see maybe i'll talk less quickly i
don't know
um
talking about under the weather
i see there's a question here from ruth
who asks how do tornadoes form
hmm
well let's see
i think the the first thing to do is to
explain what a tornado is
or tornado is a kind of a vortex in a
fluid what's happening is that the the
the air is going around in a circle
and it's going around very quickly
sometimes it can approach i think the
speed of sound um going going around in
that circle um but the point is that
once you've set up a vortex that's kind
of going around in a circle in a fluid
whether it's water or air
it's kind of hard for that
circular motion to dissipate because
it's kind of a little bit like imagine
you've got pieces of the air or the
water that are going around
and it's kind of like like you've got a
piece of string and it's wrapped around
a pencil and it's wrapped around and you
can't that there's sort of no way to
the the two sides of the string there's
no way to kind of get them to merge the
two sides are that even if they're sort
of close to each other across the pencil
that one is going one way the other is
going the other way they don't there's
there there isn't there's sort of a
stability to that
that um
exists as a result of essentially for
essentially for reasons of sort of
topology that's just like the fact that
if you if you um uh wrap a string around
a pencil you can't when you pull the
ends the string doesn't un un unwrap so
to speak now the question is how does
the air get to be going in that circular
motion
i think the answer is i think more or
less this
um so the first thing is that there is
a general process of air kind of
circulating around in the atmosphere
there's several different things that
lead to that
um the the most obvious one is that hot
air rises cold air sinks
and so you end up getting these kind of
cells where there's hot air rising cold
air going down and that produces this
kind of circular motion
in uh
in the air why does the hot air rise it
rises because when the air is hot the
molecules are running around faster
that's what it means to be hot and so
the um uh the for for a given volume of
air at
the the um
there are
the density of the air is lower there
are fewer molecules that are needed to
support a certain pressure because the
molecules are running around faster so
when they hit the walls of something or
it doesn't really walls in the case of
the atmosphere but when they hit other
parts of the air the fact that they're
running around faster means that their
pressure is higher um even though there
aren't and you can have fewer molecules
still exerting the same pressure and so
when when the air is hotter the the uh
the density of the air the number of
molecules uh in every cubic meter or
whatever will go down and that means
there's a that that means that the the
air will that air will kind of float on
top of the air that has a higher density
because that's a general feature of
things that things that are have higher
density go go lower under gravity and so
on and so what's happening is you end up
with a situation where as the air is uh
the hot air rises then it cools down
when it's when it's higher up and then
it falls again and it goes in the cycle
the circular kind of cycle and i think
what happens is that in things like
thunderstorms you end up getting these
kind of cells
um convection cells um that
are initially kind of going up down but
i think as a result of the winds and so
on and thunderstorm they get turned so
that they end up being
having the circular motion but the
circular motion is now uh you know
circles uh going sort of flat to the
ground so to speak and i think that's
how um uh that's the that's the primary
way that you end up getting these sort
of rapidly rotating uh columns of air
that are what uh what correspond to
tornadoes and i think um
the uh there's a different mechanism for
circulation in the air uh generally
cyclones
high pressure regions low pressure
regions
that's on much larger scale many miles
across and those are the things that are
closer to what lead to hurricanes and so
on where what happens is
in the um
uh let's see in the northern hemisphere
uh these things rotate in one direction
in the southern hemisphere in the other
direction um this is a result of uh
forces that that are associated with the
rotation of the earth and the effect
so-called coriolis force that has an
effect on uh when when when something is
moving
uh when you when you're trying to move
something on the rotating earth there
will be a sort of a a uh there'll be a
sort of a force that's associated with
the rotation of the earth that will tend
to make the thing sort of curl around
ultimately in a circle so you know the
place where this is uh people you notice
this if you're if you're doing something
that was noticed uh well back in the
certainly in the 1800s early 1700s as
well um people who are you know doing
artillery shelling
and you know you're trying to you're
trying to you know
sort of attack people by by firing an
artillery shell high up and it goes
several miles let's say and the issue is
that as the thing is
when the thing is sort of going up the
earth is rotating from under underneath
it and that means that as the you have
this force that's causing the thing to
sort of not go straight and it ends up
being uh you know having having a a sort
of distorted trajectory relative to the
relative to you know the people who are
sort of on the ground moving with the
rotation of the earth
so anyway that's um i think once
um once tornadoes have formed there's
this rotating vortex of air um and
there tends to be if that vortex is kind
of all up in the air you see these kind
of funnel cloud type things where where
the where you see the kind of the the
rotation of um of the air now now
typically those funnel clouds look
pretty dark
um i think the reason they look dark is
because they have lots of water vapor in
them they're kind of they look dark for
the same reason that thunder clouds and
so on look dark uh you know
something will look dark if light can't
get through it so to speak from from the
sky or the sun
and uh that happens uh when there's when
there's a high density of water vapor um
in in the thing i think that's why those
those things look look darker um but
then
what happens is the thing is twisting
around
and it doesn't have very much resistance
to its twisting because all that's
resisting it is the air
but as soon as it touches down on the
ground it's this this air that's trying
to turn around is trying to you know
churn up the ground and the ground is
will resist very strongly being churned
up and so that tends to dissipate the
the tornado as soon as it's kind of
touched down it will lose energy because
it's it's kind of like friction
operating on the on this rotating column
of air
let's see so that was uh
a little bit on that let's see we have a
question here from x why does a fan
create white noise
okay so
uh
all right so first first question is
what is white noise
so
when you
uh
when you make a sound um
it would be something like you know you
make a hissing sound
um what
um that
that
uh there's a the question of what
frequency is that sound so so for
example if you play a note on a piano
let's say you play middle c
it's 256 vibrations per second roughly
is the middle c note that's the mo
that's the main uh frequency of middle c
it has some additional ones at twice
that three times that et cetera et
cetera et cetera four times that and so
on um but uh the the main frequency that
you get from the vibration of the string
that corresponds to the middle c string
is about 256 hertz depending on exactly
how you tuned your piano but when
the the normally
when you're playing notes on a musical
instrument the idea is the note has a
definite frequency more or less it'll
have some extra harmonics of that
frequency and things but more or less it
has a dominant frequency that is let's
say 256 hertz
440 hertz for middle a you know 512
hertz for the for the c above middle c
et cetera et cetera et cetera so mostly
with a musical instrument it's just like
there's a definite there's a definite
frequency
well now imagine that you played all the
notes on a piano together
well then you'd have all these different
frequencies it'll sound pretty terrible
but
that what you can ask is uh sort of what
is the distribution of frequencies that
you hear so playing all the notes in a
piano you would have you know each note
there are 12 notes and an octave 12
semitones and an octave so each note has
a slightly different frequency you'd see
all these kind of frequency spikes from
all those different notes
but now let's imagine that instead of
doing that
that you had some process where instead
of it producing spikes at every note it
was just a continuous range of
frequencies
that's kind of what white noise is white
noise is like playing on an infinite
piano so it's a piano with sort of uh
infinitely finely gradated notes you'll
be playing all the notes together
so that there's there's a
uh frequency there's there's sound being
produced at all those frequencies
um now okay so why does that happen
in uh uh when you have a fan or
something actually a fan is not exactly
white noise i'll talk about that in a
minute
um
the main thing that's producing that
noise is fluid turbulence
and so what happens there well when you
have a fluid it could be air could be
water it flows around an obstruction
when the fluid is flowing slowly it just
sort of slides around the obstruction so
you you have your you know your
your thing in the water and you can kind
of see if you put like ink in the water
or something you'll see that it it's
smoothly you know the ink kind of the
trail of ink smoothly slides around the
object that you put into the water
that's
if the water is going slowly as the
water starts going more quickly it that
gets more complicated and instead of
just sliding smoothly what will happen
is behind the object you'll start seeing
the thing curling up you'll start making
little vortices actually the first thing
it does is to let's say your object is
like a a plate or something uh or a disc
let's say um behind the object you'll
start seeing little vortices first made
at one side they're made at the other
side you'll see this kind of street of
vortices formed behind the object
if you keep cranking up the speed even
more those vortices will start
interacting with each other it'll start
looking a bit more complicated and
eventually it'll sort of go to hell and
it'll look very complicated there'll be
a complicated turbulent wake behind the
object
so that phenomenon of
fluids becoming sort of random looking
when they flow quickly that's a very
core phenomenon in fluid dynamics the
phenomenon of turbulence the the other
kind of sort of smoothly sliding flow is
called laminar flow
and there's this transition from laminar
flow to turbulent flow that happens when
there's a certain speed of flow relative
to the size of the object and so on it's
characterized by a thing called the
reynolds number which is uh essentially
a a ratio of um the uh let's see how the
yeah it's it's uh it's the it's um uh
the
the the size times the velocity divided
by essentially the um
uh
um how how viscous the fluid is how kind
of um how much the fluid tends to damp
out
uh kind of um uh
sort of
flow in the fluid because you know if
you start a fluid flowing even even if
you start up a vortex eventually the
vortex will die down because there's
kind of friction in the fluid that's
causing that that the the momentum in
that vortex to gradually be degraded
so okay so then
okay so what really happens in
turbulence why does turbulence happen
well i think we can fairly say
nobody really completely knows why
turbulence happens there isn't really a
a slam dunk this is a simple explanation
they're are complicated equations that
describe the flow of fluids things
called the navier-stokes equations
they're complicated partial differential
equations they're super hard to solve
when you try and solve them on a
computer they tend to have the feature
that
as you sort of put them on a computer
they're no longer representing a
continuous fluid they're they're
discretized because the computer is
digital and discrete and you end up
getting these little errors because of
the discretization of the um uh of um
uh
of of those sort of of that kind of
conceptual fluid
and
those um and and it's very hard to tell
whether if you see in a simulation on a
computer if you see the fluid kind of
getting really random it's very hard to
tell whether that randomness is coming
from an actual phenomenon about the
fluid or whether it's coming from
something that went wrong in the scheme
that you use to discretize the equations
that represented the fluid now actually
i myself back in the 1980s tried to
untangle this question and figure out
where does the randomness in in
turbulent flow really come from
um the answer i think
is it's a it's a very computational
process
it's kind of you're seeing sort of one
of the one of the big things that i
discovered in the in the early 1980s is
this phenomenon that even very simple
programs
even like little tiny programs that just
are specified by very simple rules even
those tiny programs can produce very
complicated behavior it's kind of
analogous to the story of you know
you've got the digits of pi you've got a
little program that says it's pi it's
the ratio of the circumference diameter
of the circle yet once you actually run
that program you get 3.14159 et cetera
you get the seemingly random sequence of
digits
and so it's the same type of thing that
in these simple programs it's sort of
routine to get very complicated behavior
and it's sort of the the key phenomenon
is this phenomenon i call computational
irreducibility the fact that there's a
sort of irreducible amount of
computation that goes into generating
that output and it's sort of irreducibly
difficult for us to recognize
regularities in that output
and i think that's ultimately the core
phenomenon that leads to fluid
turbulence is it's a place where you get
to see that fluids really do computation
that really what's happening is there's
a lot of computation going on in the
motion of the fluid and we get to see
that that computation is kind of
irreducible and complicated and we can't
sort of reduce it and say it's obvious
it's going to do this that's why it
looks random to us and i think that's
the ultimate origin of fluid turbulence
um but that's a thing it's very hard to
to nail down all the details of that and
actually i happen to be working on
something somewhat related to that right
now
but um
the uh uh
back to sort of uh
you know the the noise made by turbulent
fluid
so what happens is
when the fluid flows around an obstacle
it makes a great big eddy a great big
vortex typically that the first thing
that happens is there's a big flow of
fluid let's say water
air in the case of the the fan noise uh
it flows around the object and um uh
it's kind of it kind of careens around
it that makes this big circular eddy
behind the object
okay so then what happens is
that
uh
uh a basic phenomenon not a hundred
percent well understood
is that in turbulence big eddies get
ground down to smaller eddies there's a
whole cascade of eddies big eddies turn
into smaller eddies which are still
smaller eddies usually called the
komograph cascade um it was uh
kind of first talked about in 1940s i
guess
um
and uh
the um so there's this phenomenon you
know at first the fluid is is making
this big addy and then the big eddy
breaks down to smaller and smaller
eddies and one of the things that
happens is that the big eddy has a lot
of momentum a lot of angular momentum
that's that's you know the fluid is
flowing around in the circle and it
keeps going and so on but as the eddy
gets smaller and smaller the forces of
viscosity the kind of the uh
the resistance to flow of a fluid gets
more and more significant and so when
the when the vortex is when the eddy is
broken down into tiny eddy it's
dissipated away by viscosity so the
basic picture of fluid turbulence is you
start off with these big ids they get
broken down to smaller eddies and
eventually when the eddies get small
enough those eddies get kind of absorbed
and and they kind of goes to just uh
stationary flow
and so
that's kind of the picture so now how do
you make sound well
when these eddies are there
they are uh when it's when when you have
these eddies in air uh you know sound is
compression waves in air and these
eddies produce sounds that are of
comparable wavelength to the eddies
themselves so when you have eddies of a
certain size
you it's producing a sound so like when
you when you pluck a string for example
you'll get a sound that whose wavelength
is let's say predominantly the length of
the string
and um and that uh and that that
determines its frequency uh depends on
speed of sound and speed speed of uh uh
well sound in the material and so on but
um the uh
the thing here is that little eddy of a
certain size will produce a sound whose
wavelength is comparable to the size of
the eddy
so okay so what's the big picture the
big picture is big eddy is made it
produces a sound that's very long
wavelengths it's very low sound you know
low sound then as the eddies get smaller
and smaller um they produce higher and
higher pitched sounds because their
wavelength is smaller and smaller their
frequency is higher and higher
and so then the question is in this
cascade
what
sounds are uh what what's the
distribution of sounds that are produced
so i mentioned that white noise
corresponds to having an equal amount of
sound being produced at every different
frequency
um in the case of of fluid turbulence
it isn't an equal amount of of eddies at
all sizes there's a distribution of
sizes of eddies it's actually in in the
the math of it is it's a k to the minus
five thirds law roughly at least that's
the sort of theoretical prediction that
the um uh the eddies as they get smaller
there are progressively more eddies um
by a factor of um you know uh the
the the eddy size the power 1.6 ish
so um
the uh
uh so that means that the
the distribution of frequencies is
determined by that law that's the
distribution of frequencies of things
that come out
from uh
from a turbulent fluid
now you know we have a very uh
sort of human example of turbulent fluid
flow which is some letters that we say
like the letter s
the letter s
involves turbulent flow of air in our
mouths
and uh that's a
and you can hear the kind of s hissing
sound which comes because there's a
whole range of frequencies and that's
the sort of characteristic sound that
something like white noise makes there's
this whole range of frequencies that's
being produced
other letters like vowels and things
like that tend to have a very definite
uh more definite frequency that that
comes about from from the uh from the
flow of air in in our throats and so on
uh usually most most vowels the the
frequency changes over time as you as
you're going from the beginning of the
vowel to the end of the vowel and so on
but um
but things like s's make uh come from
the hissing sound comes from turbulent
flow
okay back to fans
so what's happening in a fan
is the blades are going fast enough that
you have turbulent flow now
if you have a one of those ceiling fans
that's just ambling around you probably
don't have terminal flow that's probably
laminar flow but as soon as you have
kind of a rapidly rotating fan you'll
have turbulent flow um and uh and that
turbulent flow will lead to this cascade
of eddies and those eddies will produce
these sounds now okay so what's the end
result
we could actually compute what the
frequency spectrum of the sound should
be based on turbulent flow and it's not
flat like white noise um instead it will
be i will have a distribution of
frequencies it's usually called pink
noise
so why is it called white pink etc well
if we were looking at light
then different colors correspond to
different frequencies of light
and so when
white light is a combination of the
colors all the way from the blue end of
the spectrum to the red end of the
spectrum and so when we say white it's
like we're combining all those colors
together
for us perceptually us humans
perceptually we can get white light
without combining all the colors of the
of the spectrum um because we only have
we're only sampling the spectrum at
three places because we have three kinds
of cone cells in our eyes and so you
know led lights for example don't
produce a flat spectrum they don't
really produce white light they produce
perceptual white light for us humans but
you know if we were mantis shrimps or
something we'd have a lot more kinds of
color receptors the mantis shrimp would
be saying that's not a white le lcd
display that's that's an lcd display
with you know with with these specific
colors and it's not white but for us
humans we can get away with just having
uh light at particular frequencies but
the full kind of version of white light
which is also what the sun produces and
hot objects produce is this whole
spectrum goes across the rainbow so to
speak and that's why it's called white
light and white noise is kind of the
analogous thing for sound
so pink noise
is is noise where there's sort of more
at the red end of the spectrum more at
the low frequencies than there is at the
high frequencies
and um uh you can also have blue noise
and things like this
uh somewhat confusingly there's a thing
called brown noise
um and that which has a frequency
spectrum it goes like one over the
frequency squared
and um uh that that's called that
because it is the noise associated with
brownian motion associated with random
walks
i have that kind of noise but that's
that brown is not it's not you know it's
not a color word like the other ones but
anyway so i think fans typically produce
some kind of pink noise
that isn't a flat spectrum um and it's
probably the same kind of spectrum that
you would get in you know if you look at
a spectrogram for the letter s for
example you'll probably see a somewhat
similar uh frequency spectrum so that's
that's that's the story of that
um
let's see
uh
um
memes is asking how did they produce the
audio from the galaxy's supermassive
black hole i do not know
you know it's always a challenge
to
take things which are not really very
you know human familiar
and make them
uh sort of uh such that humans can can
understand what's going on i mean this
is the whole story of kind of
visualization or the whole sort of
parallel track of sonification you know
the idea of sonification is there are
things where you say i've got a picture
i understand what's going on another one
is just play me a sound and i'll
understand what's going on
solidification is generally much harder
than visualization
it's uh we've done even from
the actually version
1.2 of waltham language back in 1989 we
added in addition to the function plot
that plots
uh a function we also have a function
play
that will play a function what does it
mean player function well
imagine that you've got a function that
wiggles up and down and so on playing
that function means make the loudspeaker
cone on your computer wiggle up and down
just like you're just like the function
is wiggling up and down now obviously if
you have to wiggle pretty fast to be
able to produce a sound so for example
as i've mentioned before if you want to
produce middle c as a sound you got to
wiggle 256 times a second
um but so we have this idea of you can
play a function you can play and you you
might have some and it's very easy to
make very kind of special effects weird
you know science fictiony kinds of
sounds with play it's kind of fun to
play with um so to speak um and you know
take different functions sine waves are
good etcetera etcetera etcetera um
combinations of those and so on to make
all kinds of weird weird sounds
the question is if you are trying to
understand a piece of data
what can you do with sonification how
how easy is it to understand something
from the sound it makes
in my experience it's pretty hard
uh you know i have almost never found a
really good use for sonification
you know i don't know i'm not sure i've
i must have heard the black hole
sonification
um there are things where
uh
you know
for example
when it comes to things like well
obviously when you get close to speech
sounds and things well then sonification
is all great and we get to understand
the language that's being said and so on
but
when we have um
uh
uh
you know other other kinds of things
it's pretty hard for us to parse what
they are
um
and you know i think our brains
in our ears for example we're very much
set up to recognize particular
frequencies of sound and when we look at
speech the vowels for example have these
as i mentioned these sort of particular
frequency uh ranges in them and so on
and you know in our inner ears there's
it's kind of the inverse of having a
plucked string where the string is
vibrating and a string of a certain
length vibrates at a certain frequency
in our ears the
literally if you if you undo the kind of
organ of corti which is the main main
thing in our inner ears um it has little
hair cells in it and as the sound comes
in those hair cells wiggle and what
we're doing is we're looking at you know
what is the frequency what is the what
is the wavelength of that wiggling so
you know which pieces of that
actually there's a little bit of
it's more or less a standing wave um
not quite um but uh you know which which
hair cells are wiggling and that
determines what frequency of sound
you're hearing and we are pretty well
optimized
our auditory system is pretty well
optimized for sort of telling apart
things where there's a definite
frequency of sound there's a like a you
know there's this frequency maybe this
combination with one or two other
frequencies and we've got these sort of
definite frequencies of sound i think
it's a little bit like in our visual
system when we look at a visual scene
one of the things that we most notice is
the edges of things
and you know that's the kind of yes it's
you know there's a big blob of stuff
maybe it's a cloud or something what we
really notice is the edges of the cloud
not the big blob in the middle and i
think that's the same type of thing
that's happening in the auditory system
where we are noticing these kind of
these discrete places where there's a
sort of peak in the in the amount of in
the amount of sound at a particular
frequency
and when it's a broader spectrum it's
very hard to tell what's going on
um i will say that
there are a lot of interesting dynamics
of the inner ear
for example you know there are certain
kinds of
of uh notes when played together that
that seem like they go together like you
know you play middle c
and you play uh the note above middle c
and they they just go together very
nicely um and that's because in the
wiggles that come from from the original
middle c
the the the note above middle c an
octave above middle c has twice the
wiggle rate and so every sort of wiggle
of the of the of the uh uh higher
c note sort of fits perfectly within the
wiggles of the of the lower c note
so there are other ones like a perfect
fifth
um which is uh
the um
uh
c and g for example
um being played together on on some
musical instrument uh what happens there
is g
is more or less
three halves one and a half times the
frequency of c
it depends a little bit how things are
tuned there's a bunch of details there
but more or less it's three halves and
so again the kind of wiggles of the g
fit nicely with the wiggles of the c
well then there are other notes you can
play other combinations where they don't
fit well at all it's a big mess
and so there are uh let's see there's
one called a tritone which is what is
that ratio
oh i forget um but it's a it's a very
awkward ratio it's not some nice round
number you play that note it sounds
terrible it sounds very kind of uh
ugly to most people
and i think there are
i had a theory at one point about why
that was and it had to do with the fact
that
you are generating on the auditory nerve
okay when you have these combinations of
notes
the effective frequencies that are being
produced are various combinations
of the frequencies of those notes the
various arithmetic combinations of those
frequencies that's what happens in in
one of these systems where you've got
these sort of sounds bouncing backwards
and forwards
and i think one of the things that
happens you form okay so typical things
you form what are called beat notes
so okay so what happens with beat notes
the
the if you have a frequency of a note
little c or something like that
and then you play another note
that is instead of 256 hertz it's 257
hertz so it's really close to middle c
most of the time
the wiggles in those two notes will line
up perfectly but they'll gradually get
out of sync so they'll gradually be the
case that the that the 257 hertz
um uh
vibrations per second um note will
gradually get out of sync out of phase
with the 256 hertz one
and what happens is eventually it will
get so out of phase that what's an up
wiggle on the original note is a down
wiggle on the slightly higher frequency
note
but the what happens is that if the
difference of frequencies is let's say
one hertz uh 256 hertz versus 257 hertz
the the rate of sort of uh
you know the the the the rate at which
you go from
uh everything lining up to everything
anti-aligning is uh one hertz it's the
difference between those frequencies so
what you hear is something that goes you
know
i can't do it i'm not going to do that
well basically you hear you hear the
note sort of of a fixed frequency and
then you hear it kind of fading and
coming back and fading and coming back
so for example back in the day when
people use tuning forks to tune pianos
and so on what you would typically do is
listen for beat notes so you'd have your
tuning fork it was a piece of metal that
was vibrating at a particular frequency
and you'd tighten the strings in the
piano or something like this until
instead of hearing the thing going
you know with a fading etc it was just
that the time for each fade would get
sort of infinitely long and that meant
that the frequencies were exactly
agreeing
so
the thing that um
uh so anyway the the what happens in the
ear
is when you play two different notes you
get these beat notes you get these kind
of combination frequency type things
and i think what happens is if you play
sort of an ugly combination of notes
some of those beat notes that you get
correspond to frequencies i think around
um
maybe 15 hertz or something something
like that they're very low frequency but
they're they're they're a frequency that
is like a super annoying frequency for
the auditory nerve and why is it super
annoying it's probably super annoying
because the auditory nerve is using
those frequencies as a way of encoding
data so it's kind of interfering with
its way of transmitting data to your
brain and so that comes across as hey i
don't like that type thing
so anyway that that's um that's kind of
what happens in um
uh
in um
in that setup how do i get off onto this
topic i'm i'm now i'm sorry i've i
forgot oh yeah we were talking about
sonification and we were talking about
um how you can
you know what you can recognize in
sounds
and i think you can recognize very
little other than
a dominant frequency
or a changing dominant frequency those
kinds of things that are a little bit
like speech sounds
um
by the time you've got some i don't know
nested pattern of frequencies or
something like this
it just sounds like white noise
basically it doesn't sound
uh interesting
and um
so that's why sonification is quite hard
and and often not a great way to um uh
to kind of communicate um
the
uh sort of what's what's in in a piece
of data now i mean there are fun things
you can do like we have a project called
from tones you can find it on the um uh
um
on the web
um
the uh
um
i'm very confused by a message i'm
getting here about timing which doesn't
seem right at all
um
the uh
anyway
um
it's um
no it doesn't seem right at all
um
the uh
in any case
um
uh
let's see
i lost my train of thought here
um that's what i get for
uh being distracted and being sick at
the same time okay um
oh yeah we were talking about um oh yes
uh
okay so one thing you can do
is sort of sonify things with notes
so for example we have this project
called wolfram tones
which is a sonification of cellular
automata simple programs sort of
rendered as
uh as musical notes and essentially what
we're doing there is
uh you have these these simple programs
and you can represent them visually as a
bunch of black and white squares
you take that
time series of black and white says
going down the page for example you turn
the page around
you know by 90 degrees and then you have
something that looks like kind of a
musical score where you've got these
these uh these black squares that are
higher or lower and you simply play that
and that's kind of interesting that's
definitely sort of musically interesting
how easy it is to kind of get a get an
understanding of what's going on based
on that i'm not sure
so you know it's been a challenge and i
don't think it's it's you know people
have talked about sonification
for
years and years and years and it's one
of those things that isn't isn't quite
here yet
um
let's see
ernesto is commenting fans also generate
different speed of flow radially as the
linear speed is closer
to center than the outside yeah i'm sure
that's true but i don't think that's i
think the dominant effect in making
sounds is just turbine flow it's just
the the blades of the fan are just sort
of cutting through the air and and
making you know the flow complicated and
turbulent
um
uh
let's see
um
okay ernesto is commenting i think
they're actually trying to measure
distortion of the gas
it seems like they actually measured
managed to measure sound waves in
distant gas look i think
you know whenever
you
have
something that is kind of varying like a
wave
then
of course you can play it as a sound so
for example gravitational waves
um
you can
uh
well
you know
see the issue is in order to really have
a convincing sound you kind of have to
hold the frequency for quite a while
it's no good to just have five wiggles
because five wiggles you're not going to
hear them what you what you're going to
hear is hundreds and hundreds of wiggles
that um you know that you can kind of
lock into over the course of you know a
tenth of a second or something you say
oh yeah that's a that's a musical note
and maybe that musical note will change
its frequency over time but you kind of
need to be able to lock into a definite
frequency i think
um
okay let's see
there's a question here
um
oh excuse me
um
okay there's a question here from blank
why are roads made of tarmac
well i mean if you've driven on dirt
roads
then or been driven on dirt roads
uh you kind of have some sense of what
goes wrong with dirt roads what tends to
happen is that you get this effect
where
where you have sort of the progressive
bumps this kind of washboard type effect
where the where the where the thing that
was kind of originally flat
because sort of the the car or something
it it it bounces up it bounces down and
it's kind of grinding out the um the
road in in these ways where it's sort of
gradually it kind of grinds out kind of
a periodic pattern of what would end up
being sort of
kind of pothole-like things and i think
that's the main thing that one's trying
to avoid
is you know a a kind of a
if if you've got
a um
uh you know when you have a road that
starts to have uh sort of bumps up and
down those bumps will be amplified by
the way that the you know wheeled
vehicles for example um go over that
that road
it makes me interested to know and i
don't know the answer this i'm sure
somebody does
when there were uh paws that were
primarily used by horses and didn't have
any uh wheeled vehicles and so on on
them i don't know whether the similar
kind of uh effect that you see on dirt
roads and so on uh occurred but yeah i
think the main main thing is that you
want a kind of a hard surface
that is um
that doesn't have the ability to be kind
of eroded away
in in that fashion and you know it
depends on what kind of a road how how
how heavy the stuff that's going to be
driving down the road or going on the
road is you know something like a runway
at an airport is is very reinforced
because you know you've got a 200 ton
plane that goes to thunk onto the runway
and um it uh you know that puts a lot of
force on it and if it doesn't if the if
the thing isn't well reinforced that
will end up sort of digging a hole in
the runway so to speak which would be
which would be bad um
so i think that that's uh i think that's
that's the answer to that
um
let's see
there's a question here about um
dark matter dark energy what is it
um let's say a little bit about that
so
you know when we look out
into the sort of astronomical world and
the james webb telescope is producing
really nice pictures better pictures
than ever before of sort of what's out
there in the astronomical world
we see
lots of things that are producing light
you know the the web telescope um
it looks at infrared light but generally
it's light of some kind
um things that are luminous things that
are like stars nebulas things like that
where where we're basically seeing light
coming to us from those things sometimes
the light will come directly from a star
that's producing light sometimes it will
be going through some cloud of dust or
something and the light will be changed
by that sometimes there might be a
gravitational lensing effect where where
the light is bent by the force of
gravity around a galaxy or a black hole
or something like this um
but generally what we see in the
astronomical world is stuff that makes
light
so the question is is there more stuff
out in the in the astronomical world
that doesn't make light that's dark
matter so to speak that that is not uh
is not participating in this make light
type um uh uh or even or even uh affect
light as it comes to us
okay so how might one deduce that there
is or isn't some dark matter in addition
to the light the the the luminous matter
that we see well the main approach is to
use the gravitational effects of these
things
so when you see a galaxy for example
like our galaxy's spiral galaxy it's
rotating it has a certain rate of
rotation and you can you can compute the
rate of rotation based on or you can
compute how the rate of rotation changes
as you go further out in the galaxy you
know we're on a spiral arm of the galaxy
and you know we're we're sort of far out
in the galaxy and we're kind of rotating
at a certain speed um you can uh you can
kind of uh
you can look at different galaxies you
can figure out how fast they're rotating
as you know going out from the center of
the galaxy
and
that um uh and the the calculation of
that depends on how much matter there is
there and how much how much mass there
is there how much gravity that mass is
producing and from that you can compute
things like how fast the galaxy the
outer part of the galaxy should be
should be spinning so to speak well
turns out you don't get the right answer
based on the the matter that you can see
in typical galaxies the luminous matter
you don't get the answer that you think
you would get and there are much more
extreme cases where there's sort of
galaxies that collided and you see
something where there's nothing that
seems to be nothing in the middle but
yet it seems to have a gravitational
effect those kinds of things so that's
kind of the the concept of you know why
one thinks there's some kind of dark
matter that is having a gravitational
effect but not having an effect in terms
of producing light
now what is the dark matter nobody knows
you know there are prosaic explanations
maybe it's burnt out stars maybe it's
little black holes those are big things
maybe it's some weird new kind of
particle that is you know i one thing
that may come out of our theory of
physics
is that there may be particles much much
lighter than electrons and things like
this
that would have very weak interactions
with other things and whose only effect
would be their gravitational effect and
that might be a candidate for what dark
matter is
but people have had many different
theories for what dark matter might be
kind of if you're a particle physicist
there are all kinds of little footnotes
and rough edges to particle physics into
explaining how things work um and sort
of every one of those footnotes and
rough edges i know everyone but a lot of
them at least have had a dark matter
candidate that sort of come out of them
well you know this is a way that we
could fix this particular rough edge if
there was this extra particle that by
the way would be a dark matter kind of
thing and there are a lot of um
a lot of searches people try to do for
dark matter and they're very weird
because you know dark matter it's kind
of like well you don't see anything and
for example a typical kind of thing is a
dark matter particle if it exists comes
in and it hits something it you know it
knocks an atom and it knocks the
electron out of the atom and then you
see that electron just suddenly start
zooming off somewhere even though there
wasn't anything that sort of came in to
produce that
it's a little tricky you know neutrinos
can do things like that as well but you
know long long stories about how that
would be uh uh would work and and there
are things where you can use the fact
that the earth is presumably moving
relative to this kind of background sort
of uh um
ether of dark matter and so you can use
the fact that the earth is moving with
respect to it to kind of compare
different times of year and things like
this to to to look for it so that's kind
of what dark matter is and you know
depending on your estimates some large
fraction of the total mass of the
universe might be dark matter
um
so that that's that's that story dark
energy is actually a very different
story
um
the the universe is expanding we've
known that since the 1920s
um
the uh
you know there was this big bang at the
beginning of the universe that produced
this kind of outward
flow of uh of mata and it's that outward
flow that continues the the the kind of
the the structure of the universe
continues to expand and as you know
different there's this thing usually
called the hubble flow that is after
after edwin hubble who was the guy who
discovered experimentally the the
expansion of the universe
um the uh
uh
that produces a little force between
galaxies so it's pulling galaxies
distant galaxies a little bit further
and further apart that's kind of how the
expansion universe works you might say
gosh the universe is expanding why am i
not expanding and if everything was
expanding we wouldn't even say the
universe is expanding in fact in our
theories of physics it could be that
everything is expanding at a pretty high
rate but we wouldn't know that because
you know our measuring stick is
expanding at the same rate as the thing
we're measuring is expanding and so you
know so that isn't uh
so what really matters is that when
you're when you're just here sitting
here with you with you know we're made
of atoms that are held together by by
pretty strong chemical forces and so on
or um and uh you know we the the the
hubble flow the little sort of force of
gravity that is pulling things apart has
no effect on our doesn't make us expand
doesn't make even a whole galaxy expand
but when you get galaxies that are far
enough apart
their gravitational attraction between
each other is weak enough that this kind
of little force that's associated with
the expansion of the universe takes over
and they move further apart and as the
galaxies get further and further apart
the effective speed at which they move
apart increases
so the um okay so that's the picture
there well so now the question is um
you know
how fast is the universe expanding and
can we account for
the expansion rate the slowing down of
the of the speed of the expansion of the
universe
from
the stuff that we see in the universe on
a large scale not talking about
individual galaxies or anything we're
talking about the whole universe and um
uh and the answer is well there are some
disagreements about that
and it's it's tricky to figure out the
expansion rate you have to kind of know
when did that light that you see
was was emitted by a thing that is
moving away from us at a certain speed
sort of uh
how far away is that thing that is going
at such and such a speed and the way you
can tell how far away something is is if
there is kind of a
something that lights up there and you
know how intense
the the intensity of the light it should
produce then you just see how intense is
the light that we receive and then you
can compute from that how far away is
that sort of standard candle light and
so a typical thing that's used as
supernova explosions when stars explode
and it's kind of assumed that the
supernovas that were happening when the
universe was much younger are kind of
similar to the supernovas that happen
now
not completely obvious that that's
correct but um
the uh if you assume that then that
provides you sort of this the standard
intensity candle so to speak um that you
can use to to separately estimate the
distance and then you can figure out how
fast the thing is going away from us um
by using a thing called doppler shift a
doppler shift is is basically that the
um we talked a bunch about frequencies
of of sound and light and so on if you
hear that siren coming towards you it's
higher pitched when it's coming towards
you it's lower pitch when it's going
away from you um and that same effect
happens with light and so that's that's
how you can tell but by that change of
frequency you can tell how fast the
thing is going relative to you so dark
energy was introduced as an idea to kind
of explain why the universe isn't
uh expanding at the rate one would
expect it to and essentially what
happens is that dark energy is
essentially negative mass
matter where what one is doing is saying
normally gravity is an attractive force
it's always pulling things together but
if you have negative mass well then it
will push things apart
and and so
that's kind of the idea is well we can't
quite explain uh sort of the expansion
rate of the universe so let's introduce
this other kind of thing that's never
been seen but um only its potential
effect has been seen that sort of makes
things with sort of negative mass stuff
that makes things fly apart faster
now you know there's a lot of questions
about whether any of this is actually
right um or whether what's really going
on is something having to do with the
the the nature of uh well could be the
experiments about about the expansion
the universe although there are now
several different kind of cross-checks
that have been done on that or could it
be something to do with what we
understand about how gravity works and
so on i'm not sure
in our models of physics
one of the things okay so one one of the
big mysteries in physics is this
you think there's a vacuum most of the
universe is a vacuum you know most of
the universe most parts of space
there's at most one atom per cubic meter
practically nothing there so you think
so it's like vacuum nothing
well ever since quantum mechanics was
invented it's been known that there are
so-called vacuum fluctuations that even
in this thing where you say there's
nothing there
there are these very briefly forming
pairs of particles and anti-particles
electron a positron positrons the
anti-particle of the electron they're
formed they annihilate again they form
their island again happens in a
tiny tiny fraction of a second it's
happening all over space
and it's something that according to
quantum field theory uh there there is a
uh there's kind of a you get sort of all
frequencies of that it's actually kind
of a white noise story of quantum field
theory that all frequencies all all sort
of sizes of those fluctuations occur in
the vacuum
and so the problem with that is that
every one of those fluctuations has a
certain amount of mass and energy
associated with it and if you think that
there is a gravitational effect that
those those things
while they might have a plus charge
minus charge electric charge they always
have in the usual way of thinking about
it they always have a um
uh
a sort of positive contribution to the
gravitational effect of things because
they always have you know mass usually
apart from dark energy and so on mass is
usually positive and so
the the um that implies that there's
this huge in what you think is the
vacuum it's really seething and bubbling
with all these virtual particles and the
all these vacuum fluctuations that
produce this this you know huge pile of
energy even in the vacuum that's such a
big pile of energy that would curl the
universe up into a tiny ball maybe you
know a kilometer across or something if
you just had that vacuum energy
contributing mass
so one has to sort of explain why
doesn't that happen
the traditional explanations have been
distinctly hokey
um and uh there's a lot of kind of well
there's a thing that kind of cancels
that that's that's associated with some
other effect like a cosmological
constant that's just a term added to the
equations et cetera et cetera et cetera
in our model physics it's a lot less
hokey in fact it's not hokey at all
because in our models of physics what
happens is the actual structure of space
there is
there is inner structure to space
it's like you know back 150 years ago
people thought you know when you have a
fluid like water it was just a
continuous fluid there was nothing
there's no structure inside the water
then people realized around the end of
the 1800s that well actually water is
made of molecules and there's discrete
structure there's actually things in the
water that make up the water and this
thing that seems to us like a fluid is
made from all these molecules bouncing
around and colliding with each other and
so on
well i think that's kind of the way
space works as well and we have pretty
good evidence i think from our models of
physics that you know we've built in the
last few years that um
that space should be thought of as this
just giant collection of discrete points
and every point
just has in a sense some some friends
some point friends so to speak it just
knows what other points it's connected
to it doesn't know where it is because
there's no space yet it just knows i'm
connected to these other points here and
the thing is that when you do that you
build up this giant network of points
and when you have a sufficiently large
network as far as an entity like us sort
of embedded within the system it it
seems like it's a it's like continuous
space of the kind that we're used to
seeing
so that's you know that in that picture
what's happening is that that space the
fact that different points are connected
to each other that is coming about
because there are continual rewrites
there are continual changes local
changes in this network and the fact
that the network doesn't fall apart is a
consequence of the fact that there are
always these continual changes so in a
sense there's there's activity in the
network that is knitting together the
structure of the network in fact if we
think about sort of what's happening in
our universe the vast vast majority of
all the activity of the universe has to
do with knitting together the structure
of space it's kind of like we were
talking about vortices and fluids and
things like that
for a fluid the vast majority of sort of
what's going on in the fluid is
molecules bouncing around in a very
small scale you know and going you know
a millionth of a meter before they hit
another molecule and so on that's that's
most of what's happening in a fluid but
for us looking at a fluid on a large
scale we say oh we care about the
vortices the tornadoes whatever else um
but that's something you know that's a
that's a little tiny effect on top of
this big effect of just sort of the the
molecules and the fluid bouncing around
and so it is with space i think that the
vast majority of the activity of the
universe has to do with kind of the way
that space is formed the knitting
together of the structure of space and
the things that we're used to like
electrons and photons all those kinds of
things are little little uh sort of
fluctuations on top of uh little
structures like vortices and fluid
little structures on top of that
underlying kind of bubbling uh mass of
of things that knit together the
structure of space
so in our models you don't really have
this problem of of space has a
gravitational effect on itself
because
space is this effect that is essentially
generating this energy density in space
in our models energy is basically the
density of activity in a system what's
happening is that there's a
the that activity is what knits together
the structure of space and so it doesn't
sort of come from the outside and then
have an effect on space it's all kinds
of comes together and that means that so
space is knitted together by all of this
and so space is what it is after that
and that's kind of that's kind of the
way that that works
and i think that the uh so when you ask
about something like dark energy
um what would be happening there in our
models is there's sort of less activity
in some part of the network then there
is another part so most of the universe
there'd be some density of energy that
is sort of the the usual zero of energy
but some places there'd be a little less
activity going on and so those places
would seem like they have negative mass
negative energy um
the uh um
uh
and so so so that's um that that's the
way that works
all right
let's see well i think i'm supposed to
go to something else here not feeling as
sick as i thought i was going to feel so
uh thank you guys for for energizing me
and and um sending those viruses packing
perhaps
um i'm not sure uh
well let's see if there's anything else
i can
i can um
quickly
tackle
uh these are not quick questions they're
good questions and interesting questions
but they're not quick questions
um
actually
uh well
dad was asking does dark matter interact
with gravity yes the answer is yes
um that's sort of its point
um
then uh david is asking if dark matter
particles exist why are there no dark
matter halos associated with the sun and
planet jupiter that is a good question
i would assume that the answer is this
uh
in
okay it depends on if dark matter is
made of particles really depends what
the mass of those particles is how those
particles will behave
and
the issue is
uh okay
so
if the particles are very light
they will tend to be zipping around very
quickly if they're zipping around very
quickly they won't be caught in the
gravitational wells of things like the
sun and jupiter so they'll kind of just
be smoothed out all over the place if
the things are quite massive one would
expect them to be caught there i think
i'm trying to think whether there's a
reason they wouldn't be
ah yes i know there's another problem
the other problem is this
if you are zipping around the universe
and you're having some gravitational
effect
maybe not okay what i was going to say
is this
uh if you're going to be caught
in you know you're going to be caught by
a star and you're going to start
orbiting the star
as you
go past the star you are you're bent you
know your trajectory is bent
by
the um uh
let's see how would this work
um i'm thinking that you have to lose
energy
um let's see how does that work
maybe not maybe not
i i think okay my my thoughts and i have
to think about it more carefully is that
in order to be caught
in
the gravitational well you have to lose
energy and that if you're a sufficiently
non-interacting thing
it's hard for you to uh sort of get rid
of that additional energy additional
kinetic energy that you have not sure if
that's right
um
the uh
okay i'm going to do one last question
and then then i need to need to go
uh last question windows from wabu
what's a graviton
okay so since we're talking about
gravity and all those kinds of things i
can try and tell you what graviton is
so
uh light
is
uh
we can think of light
as a stream of photons a stream of
discrete packets of electromagnetic
energy
light can be thought of in different
ways you can think of light as kind of a
wave where you've got
an intensity about
electrical intensity magnetic intensity
you have this kind of thing that's just
electric field magnetic field that that
is a thing that's just sort of exists in
space
and the way the equations maxwell's
equations work you get these electric
field magnetic field and right angles
and that is a thing that sort of
propagates as a wave through space and
that's kind of a wave version of of what
uh
light electromagnetic energy
electromagnetic radiation is
but there's an alternative view
which says that actually it's um that
um really
you can think of it instead as discrete
lumps of electromagnetic energy that are
photons and there are cases where the
photon picture is definitely the one
that's that's most obvious like for
example very early one uh one of
einstein's early
discoveries a thing called the
photoelectric effect
where uh you know one photon of light
comes in and it ejects one electron from
metal and it's kind of like very much
there's a discrete thing that comes in
and it produces a discrete effect
so one can think of of
electromagnetism as you know
electromagnetic light for example is
broken into a bunch of photons
um we can also think of it as a wave
that comes about from the from the
collective effect of a very large number
of photons the total number of photons
in typical uh you know typical little
piece of light will be uh absolutely
huge
and so uh when you get to things like
gamma rays and so on you can have one
photon can pack a bit more bit more of a
punch and it's more more obvious that
they're sort of discreet photons okay so
for gravity it's the same kind of thing
uh for gravity there are gravitational
waves there are distortions in space
time that were about five years ago
finally detected by actually looking at
how sort of basically a a um
a thing that's supposed to be this long
when a gravitational wave which distorts
space-time goes through it it becomes a
different length and you can detect
those tiny changes of length and that's
how you detect the fact that the
structure of space time is changing as a
result of having a gravitational wave
but
there's a different view of gravity
which says just like with
electromagnetism instead of it being the
case that there is uh you know these
waves you think of it as broken into
these discrete lumps of gravitational
energy called gravitons
no one's ever seen a graviton gravitons
be pretty hard to detect because they
interact very weakly with things and
only when you have a just a huge torrent
of gravitons that would be like a
gravitational wave or something like
that would you see their effects
gravitons have a lot of funky features
they interact with each other because
each graviton has energy that energy has
an effect on other has a gravitational
effect on other gravitons so gravitons
interact with each other photons pretty
much don't interact with each other
because they don't have electric charge
but gravitons do have energy and so they
produce a gravitational effect on each
other and gravitons people have tried to
sort of make theories that are like the
theories of quantum quantum field
theories of electromagnetism where
you're talking about photons and
electrons and so on they tried to make
those theories with gravitons those
theories have a nasty habit of blowing
themselves up mathematically um and uh
and not really making sense there are
sort of some hacks around that using
this idea of supersymmetry where you say
in addition to the graviton there's the
gravitino and a whole bunch of other
particles which uh wherever the graviton
can sort of make things blow up those
other particles make things anti-blow up
and they perfectly cancel each other out
but in the usual case you know we we
haven't seen gravitons and gravitons
will be hard to detect
um and
i think
in our models of physics there
absolutely are gravitons and
there is
a certain
uh well there'll be gravitons but but as
you look at
um
very high frequency gravitons very small
gravitons comparable to the size the
elementary length going between
different elements of space all sorts of
funky things will happen just like when
you uh try and send an electromagnetic
wave to a crystal because in a crystal
there are atoms a definite separations
there there are different things that
happen to those waves as a result of
that being sort of a a
sort of discrete lattice of atoms the
same types of things will happen in
space-time and so one would expect to
see
some funky effects
um for high-frequency gravitational
waves propagating through
uh discrete this sort of discrete
underlying space time and there are some
other funky effects to do with them
uh kind of discreteness noise associated
with rapidly rotating black holes other
other things like that that are kind of
kind of more complicated to describe but
um uh you know the graviton is a
particle that's never been seen but it's
sort of
theoretically a way to describe how
gravity works is it's a stream of
gravitons being exchanged between things
just as electromagnetism is kind of a
stream of photons being exchanged
between things gravitons have you know
it's the certain characteristics of the
minoan like a photon is a spin one
particle a graviton is a spin two
particle and that has consequences for
the fact that for example uh for photons
like charges repel unlike charges
attract that's a spin one characteristic
for spin two uh all
you know like the the um
there are only things always attract and
so on all right i think i need to go
uh thank you all and um
see you another time i hope to have um
routed the virus by next time
and uh
uh until then bye for now